yes the most one  of our soldier who ever lived now brings  exciting bad  action to the American territories with  an all-new collection of authentic  regime forces and elite Hans action sets  and introducing straight from the  headlines the vile BJ terror Billy  blasts with a cold-blooded killer that  must be stopped  terror Billy is always sneaking spying  or smashing but with the help of elite  Hans and general angle you can bring  this terrorist to justice why you'll be  a hero of the empire in no time ad  terror Billy to your collection today  and bring glory to the homefront with  elite Hans the Empire's poseable  protector Fosters did this now monsters  and